Las Vegas is no stranger to construction
projects and the work underway on a
major road in the heart of Valley has
many frustrated construction has and
repairs have been happening on
Charleston Boulevard East of Las Vegas
Boulevard for quite some time now but a
new project is coming that promises to
enhance the road to Rancho
a customer think we closer because the
street has a lot of issues for over 14
years Maita mauricia has been operating
her pet grooming business on Charleston
Boulevard near 15th Street but claims
construction along this Corridor has
been a nightmare in two years almost I
don't see nothing nice right here in
France they only see is I don't have a
customer the city of Las Vegas has been
doing utility and Road improvements
along Charleston Boulevard from Maryland
Parkway to Boulder since October of
2021. according to RTC of southern
Nevada's seeing orange website this
project is expected to be complete next
month a big relief from mauricia whose
business has been barely surviving from
the pandemic before it take me 15
minutes to be here now we take me to
reform 35 minutes as one project wraps
up another one is about to begin this
38.5 million dollar project according to
the city of Las Vegas will focus on
pavement whitening sidewalks with trees
street lights among other things
stretching from Rancho Drive to MLK
Boulevard if the prayer is good maybe
it's good when they do it really fast
but when they take so long really affect
that the new project is funded by the
Regional Transportation Commission and
the city of Las Vegas which hopes to
highlight a new Medical District
including Valley Hospital
UMC and unlv's Kirk accordion school of
medicine and I believe so in Miami if
they say but the only thing if they can
do it fast
a lot of patience there all right
according to the city the new 18-month
project is expected to begin early next
year no official completion date was
provided